and I've also read about MDMA being a
big you know an effective treatment for
PTSD it's funny say that they just now
there's actually two drugs that just
came out a one of the think have you
ever heard it called on the drug on the
streets was called Special K Special K
I've heard and they're actually allowing
now people who were depressed to through
a nose spray to be able to use this
stuff which is kind of interesting but
on the other side of the coin with the
MDMA now MDMA is now being used by the
VA for combat vets who are suffering
big-time with PTSD really legally now
still probably in experimental stages
right now obviously MDMA has the ability
to go up and squeeze all the endorphins
out of your pituitary gland I'm not a
particularly out of your I forgot to
clean now but what it does is it and it
basically gives you all your happiness
right now right yeah and it's a happy
gland yeah so they so they start to look
at this bigger picture with these guys
who are suffering from PTSD and kind of
looked at that as an alternative to
possibly listen if you're not gonna
commit suicide today that's all I care
about right yeah I'd like I don't know
enough about MDMA to say hey it's it's
not addictive or you know what the
benefits are obviously as a party drug
some of the ill effects you know guys to
talk about well after I did it and I
would you know take me two or three days
to feel happy again I guess right so
that happy gland gets filled back up
again with all the right stuff serotonin
and the serotonin and I so you know when
you get if you look at that bigger
picture I haven't heard a whole lot more
about that I continue to push here at
the VA with cannabis because again no
one commits suicide on that you can't
eat too much of it or drink too much of
it and have those problems that's
amazing man does it affect their
benefits if they're using cannabis for
the vets and so actually right now yes
and the challenge is this because
federally it's illegal and the VA is run
by the feds right it makes it so that
the individuals who need it most don't
have access to it now with that said
they've actually passed some laws to
some of the other states that allow that
for the VA to be more involved with it I
think what they're doing is as an
example I have a doctor we heard the VA
now
that I have spoken to we talked about
this she agreed to work on and they
maybe do this with other vets I'm just
not aware of it with this one individual
but he had to be willing to give up
cigarettes and had to be willing to stop
drinking completely and she wanted to
monitor what happened if he just went to
a cannabis type regimen and so he's been
doing this now for about 120 days and
he's actually course the positive side
is he's actually giving up cigarettes
which is interesting enough mm-hmm
through this whole process but the
doctor now she's looking at this in a
whole new way because she said what she
sees happening it's not it's not like
it's a typical pothead I know Michael so
what do you mean she'll you know
everybody thinks about smoking weed and
laying on the couch all day long and
with my lazy ass yeah yeah I get that
but in your games and listen does that
exist sure we all know that exists I
mean I know guys who don't smoke weed
and do that little gnome who smoke weed
and read so but there's there's such a
vast number of guys I recently had a I
can say that a former police officer
come up to me and he is now medicating
with cannabis now he's retired